foreign
shines at Disney's Animal Kingdom theme
park
and at the Kilimanjaro safaris the
hippos prepare for breakfast
tequila lives in a bloat of six hippos
one of the largest in Managed Care
[Music]
every day when the hippos come out we
like to do a little produce toss to
reward them for coming out here
today in the summer spirit we have
watermelon
it's also a good chance for us to see
how the hippos are doing with eating
something that big and that solid
our Focus today is actually going to be
a little bit more in Tequila because
she's had a few tooth issues and her
mouth has looked a little sore so we
want to see how she does with the
watermelon
tequila is middle age now she's about 28
years old and that's also part of why
we're keeping a closer eye on our teeth
because she's starting to get a little
bit older
she is a very sassy hippo
she's a little bit shorter than the rest
of them but she certainly doesn't let
that affect her attitude at all
right tequila you ready
go for it
there you go come get it girl
[Music]
did she get it yeah she got it it was a
half one so she grabbed it really easy
tequila you want to hold one
tequila
that was tequila right there that's
trying to grab that whole one
seems like she can't just chop a whole
watermelon like she normally does yeah I
agree
she's clearly not opening her jaw all
the way
everybody else seems like they're eating
the watermelon pretty well
she's just eating little scraps
[Music]
it doesn't look right I think we need to
get a look at her teeth yeah not chewing
the way she normally does yeah I think
her tooth is bothering her we'll
definitely get a look at her when she
comes in
[Music]
thank you